[Musique]
j'y arrive j'arrive même très bien folio
là que j'ai trouvé dans vos peu dans vos
petites affaires
j'arrive pas mal du tout regardé ça
décontracté bien vous en servir
régulièrement
bon bah quand je me promène des fois
dans leur vie alors alors là j'ai trouvé
notre jauge qu'est ce que c'est que ces
jetons en plastique là je passe sur les
voies bien ça c'est des jetons pour les
manèges autos tamponneuses ya les fêtes
à l'onu en ce moment alors vous allez
donc régulièrement faire pareil surtout
qu'ils ont rallongé de huit jours ça
dure jusqu'à dimanche prochain
alors le soir là je autos tamponneuses
abbaoui autos tamponneuses marteau soir
à rabat le tir qu'est-ce qu'il ya des
manèges fantastique donc je viens les
forains ça vous ça vous ça vous plaît
bien c'est toujours une grande passion
pour les forains pourquoi est ce que
j'ai toujours aimé les manèges et quand
j'étais quand j'étais dans mon tout
petit j'imaginais dans la cour chez ma
grand mère comme ça que j'avais un arc
en as laissé truc les fruits qui
marchaient à 200 à l'heure parce que
votre grosse passion aussi c'est les
automobiles en voit partout
la collection extraordinaire de
christopher qu'est ce que c'est que
cette passion j'ai beaucoup de passion
disons que l'automobile bon ben j'ai
j'ai toujours eu gym et j'ai fait de la
course automobile comme quand j'avais 20
ans moi j'ai même gagné à magny cours
oui et
bon bah j'aime bien patients suivent ou
des formes des voitures américaines des
cabriolets chose comme ça pour moi
j'avais entendu parler de lamborghini
maserati au poids des voitures
italiennes anciennes publiquement
ferrari a
c'était une période c'est à dire mais
maintenant ces voitures aux américains
non j'ai comme ans j'aime encore les
ferrari parce que j'ai une grande
admiration grande admiration pour pour
enzo ferrari
oui mais maintenant j'ai des petits 43e
oui quitte maquette en revanche vous
avez des vraies voitures américaines oui
alors ça ça passe beaucoup plus de temps
parce que font les recréer il faut faire
des couleurs nacrées et oussama face
c'est fantastique parce que quand ça
roule on est en fait vous aimez bien
qu'on parle un petit peu tout ça parce
que j'ai lu aussi quelque part que vous
en aviez assez d'avoir l'étiquette de
chanteur et que vous aviez envie de
quand on vous parle et quand vous êtes
apte à jouer de parler d'autre chose de
ce que vous avez dans la vie parler de
ses passions je veux dire c'est c'est
commencer ce faire découvrir public bon
il a une image un peu quand on est
chanteur je vais dire toujours chanté
comme savons il n'y a pas vraiment de
savoir ça pas très loin de dire j'ai
envie de parler de choses que j'aime et
votre femme de toute ma vie quoi alors
les objets parce qu'à part les voitures
et aussi collection d'objets les objets
allant bon d'y aller je fais je
collectionne les pin up de commandes de
camions de routiers qui avaient devant
les calandres ouais je collectionnais
les petites voitures je collectionne et
les vieilles télévisions après avoir
parlé après et là on va voir un sujet
qui a été tourné sur les drôles d'objets
que connection persie
[Musique]
dandy un peu monde
un peu vieilli
dans ce
l'excès
il sait pas
on se souviens tu quand je chantais dans
les caveaux
[Musique]
m
v
et ça c'est vraiment mon préféré je les
ai vus sur une photo dans 77 et j'ai
flashé dessus complètement mes jolies
âge et je vais vraiment attendu
longtemps j'ai les toucher en 83 ans est
attendu après six ans et je suis
vraiment heureux de l'avoir le premier
j'ai eu en 70 après c'était un rock ola
c'est ce très bon chocolat
mais quand ça tourne à l'instar cas là
qu'il a des années 50 54 et où j'ai mis
toute ma collection
elvis presley parce que j'adorais existe
parce que alors j'en ai un deux trois
quatre leaders de couloir 5 6
les quatre du couvoir 10-11-12 la
chambre 13 dans la salle de bains 14
tient dans la cuisine 15 et je n'étais
trois qui sont dehors en restauration +
2 qui vont peut-être arriver à peu près
une vingtaine
j'ai toujours aimé les voitures quand
j'étais plus jeune c'était peut-être un
défoulement j'ai même fait d'accord
c'est mobile g j'ai même fait des très
bons résultats en course automobile
s'assume cadillac de eldorado de 57 et
j'ai une grande mais que tu me 58,0 ce
que j'aime beaucoup
ces visites parce que c'est pour moi
c'est des sculptures c'est du métal
jaune bleu métal j'ai aussi fait de la
sculpture le même sens sur métal du
magistrat suprême une expo comme ça un
jour peut-être
[Musique]